[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh hello
whoa welcome to a Red Dead Redemption
stream we are going to playing Red Dead
Redemption the first game obviously up
until we don't have read them - we don't
have it yet Justin but we will be
playing the first cave kill like Timmy I
thought we were liking Red Dead - that's
why I came in here this morning we're
just gonna cos oak in the first game up
until the reveal that is going to be
happening happening at 8:00 a.m. Pacific
that Rockstar has tweeted last week
there's some kind of announcement today
some kind of announcement I'd like we're
guessing it's probably gonna be a
trailer it might be something more
substantial like it's probably not gonna
be a gameplay stream like what we're
seeing now but I'm expecting at the very
least a new trailer so it was the same
case of last time right where they did
the exact same thing they said hey
there's you know he tweeted like a
silhouette of Marcin and said like you
know stay tuned to this time for a
reveal or announcement and it was
trailer it was 10 seconds like 10 second
trailer it wasn't it was it was 15
seconds okay so I'm saying I'm expecting
something more substantial this time
like I think so - one thing I don't
think so
since we're gonna be talking about Red
Dead one thing I don't think we're gonna
get is details on how exactly the online
portion is gonna work so then to me the
biggest question after the success of
GTA 5 GTA 5 has been so successful it's
what are the top-selling games every
single month and that's off the back of
GTA online like that game is so
successful they haven't put out single
player DLC - remember when they first
announced the game they're like we're
gonna support this they're gonna be more
campaigns there's gonna be more
single-player content and that's
disappeared but there's also not been an
outcry for like why isn't there
single-player content and I think it's
because people are seem to finally be
okay with just GTA online as the extra
way to play that read does how is it
gonna work with an online component for
that because you don't have that that
seem amount of craziness and abilities
there's by weird [ __ ] and throw it in
the game
you're right to agree but I also think
that you know it is the Wild West like
there is a level of extreme and
obviously like GTA those we're not gonna
jets sure like throughout the course of
GTA it did kind of end like the latest
update had you know you've seen the
gifts of like rocket motorcycles and the
head man wielding explosive round sniper
rifles like it's it got crazy
but we'll obviously you know that's the
online we have we probably won't see
much of that because that's it you gotta
yeah you're right you look you're
looking at the GTA 5 comparison where
the online trailers came out much later
well online that wasn't a part of the
game at launch and with Red Dead
Redemption there was an online component
but it was kind of a I wouldn't say
tacked on it was not my favorite part of
it was primarily multiplayer like a
competitive mode then did you so much of
that like GTA online no no red didn't
like no I my bad I stick to the
single-player yeah it was supposed to so
focused on that story on that that
narrow development yeah but I wouldn't
have thought GTA online would work as
well as it is it does either why well
the gta4 mod kind of set the because
they had a multiplayer mod for GTA 4 and
that was pretty dope and then when five
rolled through with an actual built in
multiplayer it's like oh this makes
sense I can do whatever the hell I want
Rob you watched GTA 5 what live
role-playing stream awesome and it's
like that world is built for crazy
things to happen all the time oh I think
Red Dead is often made for some
role-playing as well boarding well I
don't know what that my boy D is but
that's what you are just joining us just
to clarify what we're doing here as you
know we thought as most people know
there is a reveal that Rockstar has
tweeted of the we would imagine the
second trailer for Red Dead Redemption 2
which is at 8:00 a.m. Pacific we are
just kind of you know playing Red Dead 1
in anticipation and you know just to
kind of get excited for whatever they're
going to show off hopefully it's
something
lengthy but I am looking at Chad here so
if you guys have you know anything you
want to say even like questions or just
things you liked about the last game
because honestly we were just talked
about earlier this looks pretty we came
in we were like what I mean is this back
this is backward compatible on that's
we're playing on Xbox one
so you shouldn't see much of a
difference like this is still
essentially a 360 version right now I
was I haven't touched this since it came
out on 360 that was a little surprised
like I was a little hesitant I thought
like maybe it's not gonna hold up this
maybe that's a harder game to jump back
into it's not at all it looks amazing
how are they not remastered this game
how would they not put it back out they
looks like they don't need a rematch
because it looks and runs like real nice
alright so so the bigger question then
is why is this not on PC yeah it's not a
PC game I'm so good I bought a ps3 like
the second time like to play this game
in like 2012 I don't know I was always a
primarily PC gamer like rock stars
always like brought their games to PC
and they've been fairly like they run
the credit Bolton UK for pickups but
like that PC version ended up being
that's the defect of its yeah well at
GTA 5 that is how we played online
community pcs like and think about
Skyrim like Skyrim was a good-looking
game at the time but it's the mods it's
that community support behind it that
that makes that such an amazing looking
game to play today
like you put that community support
behind Red Dead on PC like it would you
wouldn't we have read that to you would
just put like play Red Dead Redemption
oh yeah it could definitely have like a
longer tail to like who knows what the
middle people
could have been on PC because you know
like we mentioned you see online kind of
took a life of its own
man like their role playing at shitty
driver whoops we have nobody imagined
role playing and uh like oh I imagine
role played in this world all the time
you guys follow the sheriff Eli from you
introduce me I still get the
notification every time he goes by so
you don't know he's like a role play
there's some cop there's like RP servers
that are smart heavy anyways able to
like literally handcuff people up and
free well and arrest them and he's
thinking he was like an actual cop yeah
Sheriff II like watching I'm like
everyone buys it right now and to
everyone who respects him they tell my
stop they're like yeah it's like full on
role playing it's just yeah Rob you
introduced Thomas snitch on you saying
how did it work when that fool comes
online so good yeah Thomas Kelly in the
chat says 15 minutes and he's absolutely
right 50 minutes until Rockstar is going
to reveal the next again we're imagining
it's probably a trailer of some sort I
think part of the excitement is like we
literally don't know
I I think we're gonna get some story so
that's the biggest question work like
does this take foot doesn't take place
after Red Dead Redemption does it take
place before now we're not gonna do any
Red Dead spoilers because I feel like as
big as an as influential as this game
was a lot of sites including GameSpot
gave this game of the year back in 2010
I think there's still a lot of people
who haven't played it so we're not gonna
spoil that for anybody but will this
take place after we'll just be getting
closer to the early 1900s will it take
place before and give you John Morrison
story and the lead-up to this yeah like
is it a prequel wasn't wasn't like I
think that makes the most sense
yeah because John Marston such a good
character like how he got to where it
was right like you know even like I can
imagine like a mission like even though
he's got that scar on his face right
Oh live dangerous all right it's worth
now I have not picked up this game until
this moment since 2010
hey that's not your boy quick you're
also on point just look like you know
what that's for I would agree with you
as far as what are we gonna get out of
this next review
we're pretty sure it's gonna be a
trailer based on what they did with the
last reveal or announcement on the idea
Twitter but you know the key thing with
the last trailer they showed it was very
much setting and the like at the kinda
like the time era not ultra specific as
far as what year but it was you know it
showed like almost like a Rocky
Mountains so like the desert so you
would imagine the next thing would then
be characters right like let's let's now
show the next thing on like even like
you know a movie brief you know like you
gotta like introduce elements of a story
narrative one by one so that would make
the most that's for sure and so it's
kind of cool like this year we're going
back to World War Two with shooters so
Wild West is something that we don't
explore a lot in games and I think
that's one of the things that made Red
Dead kind of powerful like this it's a
great medium for movies it's a great
medium for for games and adventures but
it's not something you get to explore a
lot because it's literally cowboys and
Indians like I feel like it's hard to
build around that just was like you know
limitations of the time so maybe people
are or developers are like hesitant to
like try and dive into Wild West like
you having to like invest a lot into
people invest a lot in developing games
but like Wild West is something that's
like kind of it's not for certain that
you know people are going to be wildly
interested in it unless you build
something really meaningful like Red
Dead but wouldn't you talk about what we
would expect I don't know for a Red Dead
- I don't know if I was trippin last
night or like I was thinking like maybe
the try that I like what happened I say
they blow up the train they were there
stopping the train it's this is a 360
game so the bandits shot it enough that
the train exploded okay that makes yeah
it happens
the West's wildlings sets that steam
train was full of explosives like a like
a cat instinct like an earthquake was
gonna happen you're just standing there
just look really hot yeah so last night
I was I don't know if I was fellas I had
a dream or something
last thing what if Brenda too was a
little bit after here where you kind of
have that transition to industrial
America yeah where you have like a shift
in like cars or early like yeah you have
the right if the Wright brothers come in
they bring some planes like there you go
now there's your excuse yeah and so the
one yeah when read dead 2 comes out five
years later you'll have like f-14s that
right like in the online portion there's
got to be a little bit of historical on
that chrism yeah if it comes on PC then
you can mod that in and you have Thomas
the Tank Engine like I literally the
train will be Thomas Macho Man Randy
Savage shows up so wait they didn't do
think we talked about PC did they
confirm or not confirm that they will be
super read that too yeah I have no idea
I'm pretty in the in like they're
they're kind of like closer I'm sure at
this point they've confirmed that there
will be PC boots
nah but I don't think it'll be it
release it the same way that was they
don't quote me know for sure I mean you
know
you can just kind of you could hope to
like you can hope to expected they would
they would mimic the release of APA
right fine as far as like I mean I think
about how many times I bought GTA 5 and
it was about three times for release you
know next gen or like an Xbox one or
something and then of course PC hey that
was also kind of a weird scenario where
we were still primarily on ps3 and
xbox360 that was before ps4 and Xbox one
caught on so it's like that this is the
place where we're gonna play we're gonna
play on PC at ps3 360 then we'll move
over to Xbox one ps4 yeah GTA 5 released
in 2013 which was like that literally
that transitional period between
generations and so it's like oh man is
like huge game but new consoles into an
a like and maybe I'll wait for the
next-gen version that eventually they'd
come out yeah but now it's like we're
pretty much set in stone with our
platforms
you know you get the console versions
and then maybe the PC versions a little
bit down the road like we're starting to
you look like that to stamp the Triad
yeah
oh so something like red dead I don't
know that being on PC would hurt like
being late on PC would hurt it as much
as something like destiny like to me
that hurts destiny more because it is an
online specific game it's such a timely
thing like everything right that's
needed to is timed and stuff so it's
like oh we're gonna miss out on six
weeks worth of like you know people are
already doing the raid we already know
what the rate is gonna be in a firewall
you're kind of grinding your teeth right
yeah I'm waiting to get into it but like
you know at some point you're like screw
it I'll just get you know if you do have
to be a spork well because I'm screwed
no your boy I mean luckily luckily he
you get luckily uh you know it's not so
much of a delay was it like it was like
a month for destiny yeah my PC and a
half it's a month and a half compared to
GTA which was like two years was it it
was like a year two years yes 2013 was
the initial release I think 2015 was the
re-release for a new gen and PC didn't
correct me if I'm wrong no yeah I think
that's how that's how I remember it
it's all blur to me because I know I
remember tripping about first person in
the fridge don't get off the horse
John Martha's like man I'm tired of
doing this trying to reacquaint myself
with a button so we're jumping into more
than the middle of the game so this is
the Mexico missions which is well after
the the intro portion so the intro
portion like is a pretty it's pretty
slow like a lot of setup which when he
meets the McFarland family so it's a
pretty I think it's a good idea that we
jumped into the middle here so one of my
favorite things about about Red Dead
what was so we talked a lot about how
GTA did doesn't reduce a lot of the kind
of ridiculous things that you wouldn't
get in the world I think the one thing
that Red Dead did was like let you I
think there was a unicorn there was
definitely a Yeti there was like crazy
horses and crazy creatures to find and
kill not just in holy do you remember
that yeah I remember that cuz I like
you go it's like you snowy areas come on
in the single player right yes like
there's like either side mission or is
yeah there's like going to the forest
and it's all snowy and stuff Tim it's
like big-ass Yeti him like there's a
chupacabra too is what shotgun Jesus
says that is someone's a aka and the
Wild West
so we're gonna had six minutes until
rocks are will be reviewing the next Red
Dead 2 trailer made something something
alright so we're gonna watch that live
here on the stream of course you're
welcome to go watch it or like but we're
also after we watch it once probably
watching again we're gonna probably
watch it again why not twice that's kind
of what you doing normally do right it
was watching twice and then we'll do
like a breakdown and you guys as well as
the chat can chime in we'll do like a
little bit of a frame-by-frame I have a
cool little device here that lets me
sift through frames and respray oh my
god will come break down and dissect
what they're what they're gonna show up
full brandon i'm sure there are experts
in the chat where lend us your expertise
you know there's always someone who just
knows everything
you are welcome to help us shut up -
Jake Decker our home even yeah thanks
bogeys huge Red Dead Redemption fan and
yes we probably be sitting yeah I see at
this point but he is in Australia I am
gonna play through this game again like
yeah playing this now is embarrassing
like I have played I've played through
this I really want to play it again
it'll like the feel of the way the horse
works like I don't feel like a lot of
games really nailed that I like GTA was
all about cars and like how do you
translate that over to something like
Red Dead it's like giving all these
horses different personalities and
different ways that they control and
like the horse feels really smart like I
don't you don't have to micromanage your
horse it's such an integral part of the
game so oh ho oh did you see that Jason
this is a tough part for you there was a
there was a horse on there okay and then
the train went and then it like there's
this like guts oh that's so sad that's
good splattering I'm not sure what blew
up the train there it's a it's been a
lot since I played this the train is at
full health I was okay measuring nobody
so you're tricky you do have to protect
the train we just do a different mission
let's just peruse at this point because
we're we're getting closer dwindling
down to like five ish minutes yeah
someone said in the chat we know we're
not gonna talk over the trailer for the
first two times we're gonna play it
twice you won't be hearing this during
and then afterwards we'll be kind of
going through the live breakdown
speaking of horses he kept do you have
before I have a horse now not really
speaking of horses I my old my old boss
at my previous job was a horse what's
messed up no her husband was actually
the lead programmer I think this is but
he's like a very high level programmer
and he worked on the horse animations
and the horse physics at Rockstar San
Diego cuz I'm from San Diego and
Rockstar San Diego is you know I'm based
in San Diego so yeah her husband she was
like super cool - we talked about
Finnegan when I was the tipping out to
come occasionally yo u fo negates this
type and then I'm not verbatim but yeah
she told me like her husband works but
worked for Rockstar San Diego did a lot
of lot of work on Red Dead Redemption
not like yo I played that game
I'm site he also worked on smugglers run
I told her I played when I was 10 she
was like shut up 10 that is such a cool
gig I know just like an ultra like
specific task of like making horses look
sick yeah I'm not going to workers it's
like look at like I would imagine they
would start with like first here at Rock
Terra we're gonna get you on a horse
right away yeah we're gonna we're gonna
do a little bit of a expedition you and
your horse here's a bunch of apples it's
your companion and then we'll go to the
drawing board
what's the timer about says hyped for
sickening the timer is a countdown until
the reveal from rocks are on the we
again imagine to be a decent trailer Red
Dead Redemption
- so we're playing the first game of
course honestly yeah alright until then
so we're we're the willing down what
happened what button do I push to
activate the Red Dead oh you have to
click though either lipstick oh right
stick this it might be you
now that right stick is camera behind me
okay so must be loves to does it when
someone correct me and have people lined
up I remember checks flowing pretty
quick I don't know if like or if he
aimed a 80s and then click one of those
things I let it go oh you're my friend
oh I'm seeing all caps
the trailer is happening on the website
what are they are they screaming it or
is it like a walking walk or they just
say yeah just putting it up well we have
John Luke and Eric in the back they're
gonna they're gonna they're going to I'm
sure they're frantically refreshing
their YouTube pages they're gonna flip
it and let us know just before so paint
tight we will have it here we're not
gonna talk those words you're ready get
ready here we go there it is whoo
alright so we're not gonna hear us we're
gonna lice now we're gonna break down
I'll just keep riding a horse until it
happens
[Music]
you got some money for me boy seen your
name in our ledger
you're a wanted man mr. Morgan maybe
when your father's finished mourning
your father I'll keep her in black on
your beer
we got lawmen in three different states
after they chased us from the West they
chased is over the mountains
who need an extra gun
[Music]
this place ain't no such thing as
civilized
[Applause]
[Music]
the only one of these things that our
trust
where's our money
do you have my bag
[Music]
product not yet rated oh we're gonna
play it one more time
you hang right there it's married again
[Music]
you got some money for me boy seen your
name in our ledger you're a wanted man
mr. Morgan
maybe when your mother's finished
mourning your father I'll keep her in
black on your behalf
[Music]
we got lawmen in three different states
after they chased us from the West they
chased us over the mountains
unless you gun
[Music]
this place ain't no such thing as
civilized
[Applause]
[Music]
where's our money
my bag
[Music]
product no yet rated spring 2018 spring
2018 that's that's more than just a 18
right like they didn't they haven't said
anything other than right okay yeah we
knew we knew was delayed until sometime
in 2018 and and thinking early 2018
makes sense Dutch what he was a
character in the first was Dutchess gang
he was a leader of the he was a he was a
he was a gang leader or I think before
Bill Williamson so this is definitely a
prequel based on be based on the events
of Red Dead Redemption Dutch is not
alive by the and or in some somewhere in
the game yeah so somewhere before the
first game Dutch yes so I guess this is
like we mentioned earlier that this is
gonna be some real rich backstory
leading up to or else that's what I
think is some rich backstory leading up
to the events of Red Dead one but not
directly focused on John Marston as we
just saw yeah it looks like the main
characters yeah yeah and it looks like
you're not necessarily on the right arm
like John Larson was somebody who was
always trying to do the right thing but
things let him maybe to to circumstances
beyond his control like it felt like
early on in his life he was a bad
desperado and he tried to turn his life
around
whereas this it seems like you're
starting right in as kind of an [ __ ]
like you you you were gonna be doing
some bad [ __ ] from the beginning yeah so
yeah yeah one of the biggest story arts
is John marcin's Redemption
so I'm maybe I'm not exactly seeing what
the angle is here with the redemption
name of that's probably one of the more
exciting parts of kind of unraveling
that but you know we saw the guy dressed
as Morgan and we saw a bunch of other
characters so maybe I don't know maybe
I'm thinking like some multi carry and
multi character kind of scenario like we
saw in GTA 5 right I mean that was the
from the first trailer right like the
last shot was like was it seven guys
mm-hmm seven guys you know riding out
and the
well john marston is gonna make an
appearance like 100% like yeah that's
not that will 100% happen they have to
have that character and it'll probably
be if they show it in a trailer I see it
being a lot closer to launch or it's
just something that's a smaller part of
the game like maybe you'll do some
missions with him or for him one of the
interesting things that we saw from that
is we some of the gameplay that we saw
from the first game is like what you
expect there's gonna be horse lassoing
like I feel like they threw some things
in there it's just like don't worry
that's gonna be in this game here's
there's gonna be bears to hunt it looks
like alligators to though there are
alligators in the first game there I
remember when you went up north there
were all sorts of new creatures to hunt
and fight and then you got undead
nightmare
like also when you went to Thieves
landing maybe there was alligators there
because I was by the water and it was
kind of swampy but uh I think that I got
a feeling when I was with just watching
this trailer I got a tonal feeling of
mafia 3 almost like in the way it's like
framed and kind of the cinematography
more or less all right this is no
alligators in the first one I'm Rick I'm
remembering okay over cool
there were beaver there were beavers
right in my imagination I just killed so
many animals I love the the trapping and
hunting so do you think any of that was
gameplay or was that all cinematic I
feel like I saw I feel like there were
brief moments of gameplay but I'm not a
hundred percent I think this is all in
engine you think it's I would think you
think well the games not gonna look
always that good though yeah but it
looked it look pretty good this keyboard
was working great and now it's acting a
little stiff yeah so we're gonna be
going in depth with the fancy stuff that
Rob was talking about and breaking this
down a little airy now oh and God
working and there the Legend of Zelda
theme comes up you see link riding in on
a horse paragliding and that's what
there was really the biggest surprise
for me was and Link she'll go pull out
the master something so this is the
opening shot here
[Music]
so here is like you're a dude coming
around to collect bounties are to
collect on people's debts which doesn't
necessarily make you a horrible person
but it seems kind of like you're maybe a
bounty hunter who will occasionally rob
banks yeah that's like and you know all
of this is gonna be a place you can
explore in the game like just imagine
like starting from this and then the
camera pans in it and you're just in
game here yeah yeah you can almost could
like confirm that like just that's what
the shot is really saying right like you
are on the top of the mountain and there
is a horizon that you can feasibly go
through all right so somebody in the
chat says I think when he's talking to
the kid about keeping his mom and back
black I think the kid might be John Oh
which is that's interesting I think yeah
if you guys have any you know
speculations or observations put in the
chat and we'll we'll give credit to you
oh yeah yeah okay sure yes who's this
kid John Marston
like John Marcin such an ugly mofo like
you just see tell without the facial
hair and long hair it's hard to tell
without his face all scarred up but
you're a wanted man mr. Morgan right
yeah so what like right he's talking to
so Morgan right now stuck into this kit
though that's separate so you have
Morgan talking to this kid say and like
basically it sounds like he's gonna
marry his widowed mother but he's gonna
keep him or her in black like you
establish the main character is a
complete dick which I don't think in
this game that you're just gonna play as
one character I think they're gonna take
the GTA thing which we saw in GTA 5
where you play the entire game through
multiple people's perspectives and I
feel like this is just gonna be one guy
okay so then after that there's somebody
who's telling Morgan you're a wanted man
and that's a separate people so I think
like there's gonna be like you mentioned
multi-character instances where everyone
in this gang is you know answering to
one guy and you see multiple
perspectives
so Trevor's William says he thinks John
Marsten's mother died at birth
so this wouldn't that wouldn't be doing
that Street is about to explode you can
see the red light trains are highly
explosive in the Wild West they're
really going in on different you know
environments and so we got good a little
bit of it but you know the snow section
the mouth mountainous section yeah you
know they're gonna play that up in this
like it's just gonna be a bigger portion
of each game that's pretty freakin cool
I love that tree with one branch so
Justin says keep her in black on your
behalf means he will kid - lets go
suivez he may he'll kill him - so his
mom has to wear black for his funeral -
yeah it's probably better insight then
whatever I said well hey that's
then coming out some native folk I want
to see I want to see more in the Wild
West want to see more interactions with
native tribes I think that's that's also
an interesting angle that something like
this and the Wild West should touch up
on more so you're robbing banks we need
an extra gun so you're gonna be helping
out some of the Native Americans to do
this it's probably I I do think that
Rockstar treats controversial topics
really well like GTA 5 took a lot of
different experiences and I think put
them in a really interesting perspective
and I wonder how they're gonna treat
that in Red Dead like Red Dead was more
about it was at the end of that Wild
West period when when are the way that
you know we treated the Native Americans
wasn't as big a part of that that game
but like that was a horrible huge part
of our American history
but but it wasn't something that was a
big part of that game and and I wonder
how how much Native Americans are gonna
play into Red Dead Redemption to or if
it's something that's gonna kind of
gloss over that again in favor of these
kind of more personal stories it could
be really interesting too because if if
we're interpreting this correctly is
that you know this Dutch's gang is very
like morally ambiguous you know they are
essentially you know I think people for
hire they if you give us the money we'll
do what you need regardless of whether
we think it's yeah we're on the good
side or not so there's gonna be a lot of
more moral ambiguity I think I think
there's gonna be a lot of character
customization so we're paused on this
screen here look at that mustache that's
a good mustache I tell them I wish like
that that's why we play video games
isn't it
to be things we're not yes about horse
animations bet oh oh you see is also
some that's pretty cool
we also see some horse sweat sweat
horses don't sweat yeah they do don't
think do the horses not sweat I someone
actually don't know that's true Oh who
dis guys big he's a he's definitely a
boss is that kinda in the look on the
Left lookin at
and there's also a guy just standing on
the roof he's not interested it's a
hanging out
there's chillin just a street a street
brawl well let's see you didn't have TV
back then yeah here's the alligator of
fighting a pig or a more pig gonna be
some kind of pig a wild pig isn't it
sure this is like I'm thinking of Muffy
sorry ma this is very swampy like how
big is the area gonna be for this some
like some committees and coastal
surveyor
yeah like are you gonna like that's
never been a part of like so is this
gonna be like spreading closer to
Alabama and that kind of area because
we're not Lee we're not gonna go as far
as Florida but like what part of the the
south of the the wet I mean where do you
draw that border for the West I think
yeah I was thinking like you know based
on the last trailer like you know the
Rockies maybe like some like South
Colorado you know I mean just like
you're obviously you know you have to
you have to cut your cut some slack and
like move you know areas in the Midwest
around and were to like make a good game
but yeah where how and where would this
fit in it this is like a swampy area
like rosianna but rented one was kind of
like a fictionalized amalgamation of
things in the Wild West cuz like you had
thieves landing that was swampy and then
you would go to Mexico and like be
utilized version of all the things you
would remember or you would think of in
the Wild West so I mean and you want to
be able to get to those places quickly
like you don't want to literally travel
across the United States hour-long horse
right I'm down but on
ha and here's where you come hunting for
me yeah Oh an arrow action man there was
no bow and arrow in the first was a
blaster theme also this forest looks
freaking awesome yeah look at him God
raised look at that post-processing
it has a pretty elegant elk or moose
excusing and then you hit it and he
doesn't like bursts - no no he just
explodes into like little cuts of meat
your head and breath of the wild man and
he's gonna he's gonna take it like his
bandana and float down there so I that I
do think that is that it's I'm joking
but that's kind of a point like its
breath of the wild has changed the way
that I enjoy traversing these kind of
open world environments like it's so
easy and so quick and so maneuverable
when things become more clunky like it
suddenly feels less fun for me
and it's like a hindrance that you
shouldn't have otherwise have to deal
with yeah because you're in a video game
world so how is Red Dead gonna handle
that kind of traversal when you're on
foot or is it just gonna is it gonna be
try try to be more realistic like no
you're you run down there yeah I mean
unless there's specific pathways riding
a horse up a mountain isn't gonna be
that fun I imagine oh my god
imagine this guy's you're hunting bold
peaceful just you and this moose I don't
know oh my god bear man suit
bears are horrifying state animal
they're so cute oh that's not cute cute
yeah that's so furry
oh my god that's pretty awesome though
if he was smiling that if he had like a
little cute little face he'd be like
human teeth look at him he's coming to
say hi
God screams really easy oh five finger
fillet is back and another thing cheated
as well cool strong female characters
send a tone right there you know and
that beard that beard tech beard says oh
that horrible hair words that'll work
well it's why you see mr. Wallace oh I
know it I think he probably didn't brush
a lot do they have two feet brushes no
be it's either nice and last one last
ones back that horse looked pretty tame
to begin with I don't know wise last
timing it again this is this property
look very similar what's the first thing
I can remember is not armed Oh what's
the first town you go the first drug
branch
what's the ranch I don't remember what
it's called the ethnic from the ranch
you know that's it what's where you meet
that looks like a pretty rich estate
though away yeah you're right that looks
very bougie yeah that had that main
house wasn't two stories or three in
this one so is this
do you think the gameplay will look like
this is or is this just a cutscene I I
feel like it is - I think I think this
is very representative of what the game
was yeah especially with the way the
horses eyes are bugging out of his face
oh yeah I wish we could like zoom in
like I don't know if it is he's like
looking at you we're gonna pair it
I even think I look better I mean this
is you know we're looking off like you
know a compressed video right here okay
like they think it'll look much better
on ps4 Pro X Box 1 X yeah I imagine it
better be you know I mean again spring
2018 you know they have to be at least
preparing food yeah definitely where my
money at you know who he reminds me of
is um Cameron Josh Josh Brolin Brolin
yeah old yes um first thing I thought of
- yeah
everybody sees me really shitty damn
buddy why are you talking so much about
people no you started look at this
bottom teeth a mess he's got he's got
things to do like collect money look at
that where's my retainer routine
resident money rings you know his breath
stinks
mmm his breath is wild we got back into
the wash it was a marsh oh no God this
is a heavenly of GTA and walking away as
things explode although the coolest
scene of walking away well things
explode is coming up Tom like a lot this
is not I don't feel like this is showing
a lot of stuff they're very careful with
this trailer not to reveal I think too
much new I was actually a little
surprised like how they you know as we
were speculating like story and stuff
like there wasn't all that much Layton I
guess we can roughly confirm that you
play main character Morgan right like
that he's at least one of the main
characters that you will play yes and
you could argue that like michael from
GTA 5 was like the main character you
know i mean despite there being two
otherwise he was like the most grounded
or is that the story was like very
centered around Michael de Santa don't
like it yeah whereas the Trevor Trevor I
really like Trevor that one Oh James
Ryback says dual-wield hype does this
mean dual-wielding that's what I said I
was gonna say excuse me my trying to
take his credit there I was just about
to ask that like I'm pretty sure there
was not doing well there was not hmm
he's got his eyes closed they don't even
need look just one I got some dead eye
right there the only blinking with oh
well he's doing wielding might want to
keep both eyes open okay well I find
that ultra realistic because I mean
based on my knowledge of movies most
people aren't quite blinking every time
they fire a gun it was kind of scary
it's very loud it's like an explosion in
your hand yeah yeah
Oh Mele oh look he's so back at that
barn that barn is just covered in skulls
hunter yeah but why I really the bones
if I feel like those are just things you
found okay
this savage is about huge antlers ball
right in chess and just oh that hurts
yeah look at that outfit so this again
like riverboat gambling like this says
to me riverboat gambling yeah look those
shiny butters look at that vest got like
a nice print to it the red thing pink
things I would wear that yeah what's
worked out what sweat out tomorrow and
to get that soul patch right under is he
looks like someone you wouldn't want to
lose or win at any kind of gambling game
look at that Marines - mmm he's a baller
yes some velvet vest
oh you somebody want to be friends with
and that mullet love mullets Melissa and
I'm walking away house on fire Oh easy
homies nice yeah he was robbing his
house gonna get that insurance money
that maybe what if that's like the
richest state that we saw in the
background when he was last wing that
horse yeah it's maybe it's like a plot
twist in here where you're burning down
the main characters house with your
homies man how cool would it be to like
go full-on like customized customizable
characters for like online like anything
I'm getting real specific but like a
pocket watch what would he call it that
thing you put in your hanker hankie yeah
chief can customize that to your ascots
a Scott's dead ascot an ascot yeah a lot
of possibilities that's the end right
there it is go back to last shot see if
we can pick anything there that bad that
horse is slow horse is ripped what I
mean they run a lot that's yeah they
better be strong they're basically just
constantly on their feet they're
constantly on the leg doing they
literally cannot skip leg day what's he
shooting there's a Oh pre-order now
spring 2018 there it is
so right now this is also just confirmed
for ps4 and Xbox one should we play the
full trailer again one more time
sure we'll probably have to do it in the
back that's got you we got it let's
watch it one more time and then wrap
this stream up
we know you even love listening to us I
do yeah thank you don't ya I have to
listen to y'all every day I don't
[Music]
you got some money for me boy
seen your name in our ledger
you're a wanted man mr. Morgan maybe
when your mother's finished mourning
your father I'll keep her in black on
your behalf
we got lawmen in three different states
after they chased us from the West they
chased us over the mounds Lila suka
[Music]
this place they no such thing is
civilized
[Applause]
one of these that our trust
where's our money
Oh
[Music]
no you have waited so now that we got to
look back at it the guy in the really
nice vests and the has that presence is
Dutch so yeah I'm gonna be answering to
him I suppose that's how I see it and to
a point right
maybe burning down that house and I
answer to nobody that's it you said that
to Iceland I I want to see more god oh
I'm ready to play it I want to replay
Red Dead Redemption
alright wait yeah I mean you know just
by playing earlier just on the stream
like I think it holds up like for sure
yeah that was fun thank you guys for
joining us and stay tuned for more Red
Dead coverage down the road I'm sure we
have a lot more and I wonder if you know
we just been sitting here watching a
trailer I wonder if they've announced
anything else
probably not I think that's usually
trailer next year but I'll get another
trailer okay talk to you next year
that's about like Star Wars exactly by
the way Star Wars October 9th is
apparently the next trailer for last
Jedi so are we gonna do a stream for
that too if we know what time exact time
on that Monday it's Monday Night
Football is when people been saying that
to Star Wars trailer but yeah let's see
but anyways that was fun thank you guys
for chiming in the chat and sticking
with us that was a fun time yep cool
thank you for having me on this early
morning on the west coast oh let's go
say yeah yeah stop it's like we had to
wake up for a real job yeah it was it
was surprising now I gotta get some word
I'm now I'm gonna go take a nap oh yeah
yeah let's take naps that sounds pretty
cool alright guys well thank you so much
I'm an excellent rest of the week see
you next time
[Music]